[Music]
the border crisis coming to president
biden's front door as states brace for a
surge in illegal crossings once the
white house ends the trump era title 42
policy which allows border officials to
quickly deport large groups of migrants
texas governor greg abbott making some
big news after announcing a plan to bus
migrants from his state to washington
d.c but conceding today that it would be
voluntary
joe biden has refused to come to the
border to see the chaos that he has
created by his open border policies so
we're going to take the border to him
with regard to
the voluntary component of it understand
this and that is uh dana if i were to go
to washington d.c
and and take you and put you on a bus
and take you down to the rio grande
valley that would be kidnapping same
thing applies to anybody who refuses uh
to get onto a bus that would be
kidnapping even though it would be by a
law enforcement agency so there are laws
that have to be found on this process
the white house heading back at governor
abbott's announcement
now that the texas governor is saying
that he's going to start busting border
crossers to washington dc when they get
here are you guys going to help them
find a place to stay and something for
them to do well i'm not aware of what
authority the governor would be doing
that under i think it's pretty clear
this is a publicity stunt i know that
the governor of texas or any state does
not have the legal authority to compel
anyone to get on a bus republicans
aren't the only ones sounding the alarm
on title 42 a growing number of senate
democrats are also raising concerns with
what ending the policy will do to their
states many of those jesse are in tough
re-election races but not all
man if i came from el salvador and i
made it to texas and they put me on a
bus to d.c i would be i'd want to go
back to el salvador have you been down
there recently i got to clean that place
up shellenberger your friend out in
california said the other day on rogan
show which i'm listening to now it's not
bad he said the left is obsessed with
what we call radical hospitality where
they will just allow people to just
shoot up drugs in the middle of the
street in broad daylight or just waltz
into the country with their hands out
and that's what's happening now i knew
parents like that who had kids that let
them do whatever they wanted and these
kids turned into disasters and that's
what joe is doing to this country the
feds are responsible for immigration but
if the feds are going to be
irresponsible and not enforce it then
the states can't just lay down they have
to do something
abbott had operation lone star
unveiled last year where they put about
10 000 national guards down to the
border to nail people for trespassing on
private property but it's costing a
fortune so now his hands are tied he can
only do so much this is just a stunt to
embarrass the president into actually
doing his job and then they give him
phones right first they have the obama
phone remember the obama phone now they
have a biden phone what are they going
to give them like signed copies of how i
saved the world
i mean how much free stuff are these
people going to get you give them a
thousand dollars you give them airfare
and you give them a phone can they
download apps can they tweet hashtag i
made it to estados unidos this is absurd
and everybody knows that you don't need
a phone to be able to track people do
you right all you need you know when you
go to the deli and you try to get in
line they give you a little slip of
paper that's all you need
what the date is and where to show up if
they're taking this seriously that date
is the most important date of their
lives i think they can commit it to
memory and if they are actually using
the phones as a tracking device then
good if they don't show up to the
hearing then go find them and deport
them but they're not doing that
joe biden not only can't well legally
maybe not but they should and joe biden
has not only broken all the records on
illegal border entries he's also broken
the records for the least amount of
deportations and that's by design
opening the border is the best thing
he's actually done is in his
administration is this your monologue
because he's doing it on purpose yeah is
that your mom
come on come on
the white house press secretary jensocki
talked about the phones today if you can
play that sound for us thank you
we need to take steps to ensure that we
know where individuals are and we can
track and we can check in with them the
alternatives to detention program is
what we utilize as three unique forms of
technology to monitor participants
enrolled in the program any concern by
folks around here that these migrants
will take the phones and just toss them
do you have a record of people throwing
phones away just asking if that's a
concern
our concern is ensuring that individuals
who
irregularly migrate to the united states
proceed through
our process of
you know of course being monitored but
also participating in uh in uh
in hearings to determine whether or not
they will be able to stay
judge jeanine what do you think of all
this this is political theater that's
all it is the biden administration by
ending title two title 42 is being
reckless with the economy
with national security as well as with
our health you know by by making sure
that we still have kids massed in
schools while they've been coming
through the border since january of 20
of 21 uh without even being tested i
mean why are they being treated
differently but here's the thing that's
most interesting about the phone you're
going to give these guys a phone and
she just said so that we can check in or
track them the way they plan on doing it
is with some kind of biometric they're
saying that they take the voice imprint
and then they can be sure that the
person who answers the phone is a person
they gave the phone to that's hogwash
and i'll tell you why they don't have
the number of people in the in the
homeland security to make the phone
calls to check in on them they don't
know where they are they don't know if
they threw the phone away they don't
know if the phone is is charged or not
charged this is this is nothing more
than theater and so here's the question
what is the president's end game here
when they give these old excuses like
you americans we're going to shut you
down but all you illegals you come
through and we don't care who you are we
don't care if you're ms-13 we're not
going to discriminate okay and then they
say you know what if you need asylum all
18 000 of you are coming through a day
which the way i figure it is almost 150
000 a week which is about 300 but what
one three or six hundred thousand a
month we're going to be able to have
them call and we're going to call them
back who's going to pay for this we are
what is joe biden's end game what is he
looking to accomplish in this country
jessica do you want to answer that
so i don't think that this is where joe
biden actually wants to be so there's
been a lot of pressure from immigration
groups on them from the left flank that
are saying we need to get rid of this
title 42 which by the way is a public
health measure it's not an immigration
policy so we need to be clear about that
this was put in place when kovitz
started sweeping the world to make sure
that we were not letting people in here
who were infected with the disease
certainly before we had vaccinations so
first and foremost that joe boy joe
biden is part of a group of moderate
democrats including hillary clinton and
others who have talked about stricter
border enforcement over the years so i
don't think that this is his natural
position on it
but when you do look at the studies in
terms of people who do show up for that
court date as jesse said the most
important date of your life
it's a large percentage of them it's
majority and in some studies it's over
90 of them in terms of the calls i don't
think that it's going to necessarily
work that they have a phone and they're
going to call and check in and that we
have the staff to do that but what we
need is a cohesive immigration policy
here that's going to satisfy those
border democrats like kelly and cinema
and frankly the president the united
states of america but picking on title
42 as part of this when it's just a
public health measure doesn't get us any
closer to that policy but that but
but just yesterday the biden
administration said if you have a
student loan you don't have to pay that
because of the public health measure
right but title 42 they're going to get
rid of because they don't have a health
crisis yeah and we still have kids in
new york who are wearing masks under the
age of four uh i think that the problem
with the phone thing is it's just a
waste of money but it doesn't matter
because it's our money
i think that's the big problem i you
know i'm for stricter border enforcement
but i will take five illegal immigrants
over one gender studies grad any day but
that's not the issue it's not about the
people it's never been about the people
it's always been about the process you
know we all
americans kind of want the same goal we
love immigrants they come here they
become great americans sometimes they're
better americans than the americans we
got here we kind of know that the thing
is though when you're a republican or
you're a libertarian you're kind of also
into the idea of a process or a system
not just the goal and the dem and the
democrats suffer from only having goals
and no systems this idea of transporting
uh illegal immigrants to d.c or texas is
is this kind of a i mean dc or uh
delaware
um
it's how you should deal with landlocked
privilege you know big cities delight in
in cheap labor of illegal immigrants so
they scoff at border states who are
driven to exhaustion because they got to
deal with the problem right there and
then they're often called racists for
trying to do the right thing we still
haven't seen the investigation of of
whit gate in which one guy you know one
border dude was just demonized because
he was trying to control the border but
these are issues that the dems ignore
because they don't feel the
repercussions with the crime wave
there's no repercussions because they
get private security lockdowns and masks
they still get to go to the french
laundry right they can still take
selfies with celebrities then you have
the border it's not their state but i
get the people to do my dishes so there
you go so i like the idea of actually
even
it's got to be possible i think some
people will get on the bus they might
you know delaware's a nice place i've
been there d.c there's some nice
neighborhoods if you know where to go uh
and the democrats shouldn't complain
about this because they were the
instigators with sanctuary cities where
they chose to virtue signal this false
compassion at the expense of their
citizens can i can i say one thing dana
you know one of the things that jen
sachi said she said nearly 80 percent of
non-citizens released at the border in
dhs custody under prosecutorial
discretion have either received a notice
to appear or are within the window to
report so actually the vast majority of
people are appearing that's not the case
but i mean everybody knows that's not
the case 80 percent of the illegals
who've been told you know show up at
your local immigration office are not
coming in and in fact there are two
studies here that said it's more like 83
percent are not reporting and 80 are not
reporting so i mean that's all theater
there you also had secretary mallorca
say that it's impossible to predict what
could happen uh when cell 42 is lifted
i'm like no we know exactly
what's going to happen we've seen it for
the last few years hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else